next question
why is fluoride the one supplement we
mass medicate with and what are the
potential benefits and harms especially
for babies
so again we could go forever and in fact
i have done enough um
i've done enough just literature review
on this that this is now
my i don't know if you get these but i
get like weekly
updates from the princeton library about
new papers that i might be interested in
and like fully half of them are about
the risks of fluoride of fluoridation in
water supplies and to salmon
and like to just just everything so
um yeah why how but but the question at
some level is
um well there's three different
questions here and this could fill
many many hours but i don't actually
know the history
actually my my d.o knows some of this
history
it's preposterous um of how it is that
we came
oh wait it's industrial waste or
something isn't it okay
you tell the story well i don't know it
well yeah i should dig deeper but yeah
basically it's a it's an industrial
byproduct
yeah um and not all fluoride like
fluorides and elements
chlorine is an element yes but okay
first of all fluorine
is the element highly caustic elements
so we're talking about fluoride salts
but there's also an interesting
nuance here where if i recall correctly
the the evidence which is weaker than
you would imagine
for fluoride's benefits is actually a
different salt
than fluoridation there it is right yeah
um no
it's actually like so
it seems pretty good that so you you end
up with
um there's some the the early work that
caused the fluoridation to start
happening
in municipal water supplies actually i
think seems pretty good but the fact
that it's a different form of fluoride
than what is now being put into the
water supplies is the
is the big crazy part of the story that
um we're
sort of not talking about yeah i wish i
wish we had the the names of the two
salts
uh at our fingertips but it's been too
long but in any case
um a it is insane
to medicate this way because
it does there's no controlling for who
drinks how much water right
right so this would be an insane way to
go about this uh
process even if this were justified but
as i recall the evidence is far
weaker than it should be and
there is evidence there is evidence that
conflicts with it where you see the same
increase in bone strength and teeth
durability in populations that didn't uh
fluoridate their water but anyway
what about fluoride toothpaste i think
the fluoride in toothpaste is the same
stuff that's put the municipal water
supplies right it's also the wrong
fluoride salt
yeah i think again i'm trying to i don't
want to reverse the two salts but in any
case
um this is not however the only case and
in fact i believe the evidence in the
other case where we do this
is actually that it is positive and
worthwhile what's that
iodine and salt um
so iodine in salt it's interesting you
say that because we
like we i don't buy us right salt at
this point
right and i don't complain about it
because we get enough of this stuff
in interacting with the world there's
enough iodine
the basic point is you're trying to
you're trying to hedge out
a deficiency yeah and there's no value
to it above that
as far as we know but the deficiency is
very serious but i mean it's also
possible to
to have too much no yes short i mean
short term
uh one one wants to
find a happy medium and my sense is um
we're getting enough iodine just by
virtue of the fact that we you know go
out to eat occasionally and
you know there's salt and everything
what not anymore
well that's true and actually maybe that
should alter behavior but my sense is
that the
eye so the iodizing of salt solved
major issues um where it was done i
don't remember where iodine comes into
the diet
naturally um i feel like it might be one
of these things that's in trace amounts
and things like dark leafy greens and
meat
i believe that's right yeah um red meat
but
uh but in any case i think um the
the fluoridation story and the iodine
story go in opposite directions now
no doubt there is a less crude way
because if
the iodine issue has exactly the same
problem as the fluoride issue which is
that depending upon how much salt you
eat
um this could have uh you know very
different effects
yeah um and so it's not a good way of
medicating because there's no way to
titrate it
yeah incidentally um so melinda here
writes i find it frustrating that
opposing the mass fluoridation of water
is considered so fringe this is one of
the places where
um you know portland the populace of
portland that
you know cannot figure out how to get
our government to stop the assaults on
businesses and such that are still
happening apparently still happened in
the pearl district last night
however have um have kept
fluoridation out of our water supply um
they did and i don't know if you recall
this
but actually this happened before we
moved here as well i referred to it as
well before yeah
yeah like the the it's it's sort of
settled now like and you know
it's always an attempt i guess it will
come back but it's pretty established
like no
portland is not going to fluoridate the
water portland will not fluoridate its
water
yeah like olympia now yeah here's that
oh i didn't even know we were on a well
olympia so i didn't pay attention
olympia didn't fluoridate either and you
know why because
evergreen faculty got in the way of it
so
this is actually a really interesting
case where the thing that went crazy
started out not so crazy or at least is
not crazy on different topics many of
the same people
right so anyway i think you know
as it's often the case there's there's a
story to be told here
about you know where where once you i
mean look most of our faculty colleagues
were crazy but those were several
generations down the road
of faculty they were only the tiniest
number of founders
uh still at the college when we got
there and you know none of the founders
that we knew
or knew by reputation were crazy no they
were all terrific
they were great the founders and the few
people who were hired in the first few
years of the college
not founders like um like you know mike
bug
uh who's a chemist yeah uh i know we
never i at least never talked to him
about um
fluoridation but i imagine that he was
opposed to fluoridation
yeah right oh no doubt yeah no doubt
yeah um and you know so in any way we
knew
some of these people the handful of
people from the very early years of the
college
were eccentric but not crazy and
the um anyway their their early
opposition was the reason that the
olympia didn't didn't fluoridate um
someone asks i have a well so i don't
have fluoride in my drinking water
uh what effect is not getting fluoride
get so you know the
really the the only thing that fluoride
is um
supposedly doing is um
is strengthening bones and teeth
yeah and um and not
in the form that it is in toothpaste and
uh
and water municipal water sorry stalled
out so
yeah like you know how how are we
supposed to get it well
you know i don't know i actually with
fluoride i don't know like i'm
well i have very little doubt that the
answer is if you
eat a diet that is um i feel like this
is it
yeah but so like i mean we pulled we
stopped using florida
fluoridated toothpaste on with certainly
for our kids because kids are more
likely to swallow the stuff
um and for us years ago and you know
much the chagrin of our dentists
um when we tell them yeah um
so yeah yeah cereal has everything added
right it's like a multivitamin with some
grains
claire seguin who i read is carl sagan
for instance um suggested seafood and
seaweed has it
here's the thing we've stopped eating
seafood out of the pacific which is a
huge loss to us
because of all of the
radionuclides that were spilled into the
pacific
after fukushima which have made their
way
into uh at least
tuna and salmon at alarming levels at
least
so these things are not it's not easy
the data is not easily available now but
right after fukushima happened
this stuff was measured and the levels
were absolutely they weren't high in any
fish yeah but the
frequency that they were found in tuna
was 100 percent
yeah and it was very common in salmon
and so anyway we
uh on the advice of arnie gunderson
stopped
eating pacific seafood and without data
we haven't gone back to it
there's actually very little reason to
think those levels will have dropped
because
the half-lives of the important
radionuclides are very long
not super long but 30 years
so anyway yes eating seafood would be a
great way to deal with it but we're now
in a pickle which is that all of our
seafood comes out of the pacific and we
don't consider that safe enough
because of
[Music]
uh the uh strontium and cesium that
was lost in the pacific yeah um and um
yes an excess of fluoride turns her
teeth brown that that is actually as i
if i remember correctly
how it was um
how the original fluoridation was
understood to be helping that um
some town in colorado i think happened
to have a lot of fluoride in
the drinking water from underground
sources i don't remember the specifics
um and so some dentist was just seeing a
lot a lot of people with
with brown teeth but also with fewer
cavities sort of notice that as an after
effect it went like ah maybe brownness
and and no cavities is correlated and
and attracted back to the fluoride
that's salt of fluoride that was
actually both protective against
cavities
and tended to de-whiten your teeth
yeah all right hey guys that was a clip
from our monthly private q a that you
can get access to
at my heather heing's and you can also
get access there to
all of the past paid subscriber content
so please consider joining us there
did you mention that these private q as
are the key to living a better life and
living to tell the tale i forgot to do
that
these private q and a's are in fact the
key to living a better life and what
living to tell the tale living to tell
the tale
go ahead live to tell the tale join us
there see ya